ils sont mollahs beau fils numismate ou
encore les sites zoophiles autrement dit
ils sont collectionneurs d'anciens
moulins à café de pièces de monnaie ou
de flacons de parfum ces passionnés
d'objets d'hier ou d'aujourd'hui
exposent leurs trésors jusqu'au 2
février à l'espace decaux villes de
voisins-le-bretonneux une exposition
multicollections organisée par le club
des collectionneurs des yvelines le club
réunit un certain nombre de passionnés
une cinquantaine qui se réunissent une
fois tous les deux mois et partagent
leurs trouvailles de toute l'année et
essaie de les mettre à la disposition du
public au travers par exemple de
l'exposition d'aujourd'hui
je suis donc un faux mail qu'au fil
autrement dit quelqu'un qui collectionne
les tire-bouchons j'ai une petite pièce
effectivement du xviiie moitié du xviiie
qui est donc à un tire bouchon à parfum
qui est en argent et qui a et qui a
comme une certaine valeur on peut nous
pouvons dire donc aujourd'hui les
tire-bouchons anglais dont j'ai quelque
chose mais une préférence parce que nous
aurons par exemple des manches en corne
d'autres en ivoire d'autres dans des
bois précieux je considère que pour
l'instant ce sont les maîtres en la
matière si vous dénicher des trésors
dans vos greniers vous pouvez faire
appel aux collectionneurs du club des
yvelines qui peuvent vous aider à les
évaluer